I had to transition the company was just
sold so we had to move out of semantics
into our own space and went through a
full RFP with different cloud provider
as well as data center providers and
came to a realization IBM cloud and
VMware was the right solution for
Veritas IBM was the first one that
actually had the offering both on the no
bare metal as well as the VMware stack
and VMware cloud it was the only
solution that made sense
nobody else offered the spectrum of the
options
I'm hybrid but 95% in the cloud I really
wanted to have a very seamless migration
to anywhere because the company was
already like the open architecture that
IBM cloud provided the bare metal that
IBM cloud provided it allowed me to both
use our own product Veritas product and
VMware tools to be able to move live
workload with minimal to no impact to
our business you know on a Friday night
go home and by Monday morning they come
in everything is working they don't even
know that I moved them that was
important the big win for IT is not to
interrupt the business we moved 95% of
our enterprise applications into IBM
cloud both on the bare metal and VMware
and out of the thousand workloads
running on IBM cloud out of those about
80% to 90% of it is running on VMware
and other ten to twenty ten to fifteen
percent is running on bare metal servers
you know even though I'm on a public
cloud I have the security of a virtual
private cloud being the chief security
officer it enables me to have a little
bit more sleep
[Music]
the bear medal has been the key for me
but we have lots of applications that
they've been there forever
now the next journey is the application
modernization to truly make them cloud
aware and utilize the services that is
available to us
[Music]